we've owned our Tesla Model y for just
over a month now that's allowed us
enough time to experience all the pros
and cons technically Teslas are
considered a luxury car but if you stick
around to the end of the video I'll tell
you exactly why I think they're not
luxury cars but they're in a whole
different category of their own what's
going on guys my name is David tomich
I'm a registered architect here in
Western Australia and on this channel we
talk all things architecture and
technology today we're breaking down the
30-day experience of owning a Tesla
Model Y and exactly what it is like to
own one first hand so let's dive in with
all of the pros first things first
something that most people would
deliberate for a very very long time
including myself when purchasing this
vehicle is the Tesla Model y white seats
now obviously in the back of your head
you're thinking white seats incredibly
hard to keep clean and God forbid
anything spilled on them or there's any
dust or Grime on them well so far so
good in actual fact the white seats have
been incredibly easy to keep clean and
all we've had to do is baby wipe them
down every now and again and to be
completely honest having white seats
actually kind of forces you to clean the
car a little bit more and keep it
pristine nice and clean which is its own
added benefit when they're black seats
you kind of stop caring about it pretty
quickly and you're just like well it's
black seeds nothing shows nothing
matters so at the end of the day those
black seeds after a couple years are
going to be disgusting and filthy whilst
those white seeds are going to still be
pristine brand new and sparkling clean
along with the white seats the minimal
interior is by far something that stands
out and striking everybody who looks at
the car goes wow there's nothing in here
and that's exactly why I love it now
Tesla's in general not just the model y
tend to be purchased without ever having
test driven one we for example purchased
the model Y without ever test driving
the model y we test drove a model 3 just
to see what it was like and in all
honesty the three and the wire Drive
incredibly similar even though the model
Y is a big SUV car it is still quite
easy and quite practical to drive around
town unfortunately one of the cons in
this category is the simple fact that
the Turning circle is not the best it
isn't the worst at the same time but
it's definitely not something that
you're going to be wanting to go around
tight Corners in all the time something
that you get very used to very quickly
in a Tesla Model Y is your phone key and
not having to carry around any Keys
obviously with solar Customs carrying
our phone around everywhere with us
nowadays that we don't even think about
it wherever we go the phone's in our
pocket so having the phone act as your
key has been so convenient you literally
just walk up to the car it opens up
basically 99 of the time it works
flawlessly there is that one percent of
the time where it just doesn't work and
stick around to the end of the video and
I will share with you that one percent
experience of why it's a little bit
frustrating now when you go ahead and
audio Tesla Model why you see that
glorious shiny package at the end Tesla
autopilot ten thousand dollars well if
you're not already aware Tesla actually
gifted a whole bunch of Tesla owners
free 30-day autopilot for Christmas in
2022. so for the last 30 days we've
gotten to experience the Tesla autopilot
and in all honesty in Australia right
now it's 100 not worth it it does not
auto drive it does not Auto steer on
city streets it's basically just
slightly enhanced autopilot that already
comes standard with the car and in the
real world you're most likely just going
to use the basic autopilot 99 of the
time talking about spending extra money
the Tesla premium connectivity obviously
comes standard with a car free of charge
for the first 30 days as well in my
personal opinion you definitely don't
need to upgrade and pay the money every
single month to get premium connectivity
premium connectivity basically gives
your car Wi-Fi allows you to connect to
Spotify and all things during your drive
whereas in reality most of the time
you're just going to be sharing it
through the Bluetooth your phone and if
you're just a sole driver you probably
shouldn't be playing with the screen
while driving anyway whereas if you have
a passenger it's not that hard to open
up the phone and change Spotify for ten
dollars a month or whatever it is I just
don't think it's worth it even though
it's absolutely minimal in the grand
scheme of things now something that I
personally think is incredibly unique to
Tesla and especially the model Y in
Australia because the launch was so
highly anticipated is the community that
is built around it for example in
Western Australia there's a huge
community of Tesla owners and especially
Tesla Model y owners in the recent
months because your auto Tesla online
just like you order an iPhone you have
no idea what you're getting you don't
get much customer service but that's
kind of the whole experience so you dive
head on deep watch videos like these to
understand exactly what you're about to
get and exactly what the experience is
going to be like and you end up
connecting with a whole bunch of people
from your community that also Drive
Teslas you quickly realize that when
you're driving the Tesla around town as
well it is this strange little Community
feel that everybody waves to each other
says hello as they pass each other by
now I don't know about you guys but I
have not been in any other car where you
drive past that identical car and
somebody waves at you if you have make
sure you leave a comment down below
because I'd love to know know how many
other car brands have this sort of cult
following obviously range is one of the
biggest concerns in an electric vehicle
and Teslas and all electric vehicles
have come so far our Tesla Model y came
brand new out of the factory with 435
kilometers at 100 charged on the website
it promises 455 there is absolutely no
way I would expect anybody to get 455
from a full charge when you jump onto
Highway streets and are driving at 110
kilometers an hour this 435 is a
complete and utter lie maybe you could
get that kind of range if you're driving
50 60 kilometers non-stop but once you
actually hit highway speeds that drops
significantly in my personal experience
if you're willing to push it all the way
to zero and risk your battery going
completely flat on the side of the
street you can potentially get away with
330 kilometers maybe a little bit less
but roughly around that 300 kilometer
Mark is the realistic expectation of the
battery most of the time we go about 200
kilometers and we can't make it to our
destination because most of our
destinations living regionally a three
four five hundred kilometers away and in
wa we definitely do not have the
infrastructure to support long road
trips just yet yes the government has
introduced all sorts of EV charges
coming up and Tesla is slowly very very
slowly implementing new supercharger
locations but for example for our very
frequent trip up to the capital city in
Western Australia which is about 450
kilometers away there's only one
supercharging location if you ordered a
white Tesla Model why like we did then
you've probably heard already that the
paint is somewhat garbage already we've
gotten a ton of Chip marks and stone
marks from the drives and from the
trucks in front of us which is quite
disappointing and disheartening because
it's only about 30 days old so in the
grand Long plan of keeping this car for
eight to ten years it's probably going
to be completely trashed by the end of
it but hey it is what it is and that's
just unfortunate certainly what Tesla's
basic paint package is if there was a
premium white option available 100 I
would recommend going up to that premium
white there isn't there's just a whole
bunch of other colors which personally I
wasn't too keen on the gray was
potentially nice and the black was nice
but the white was still one of the best
colors in my opinion now this next con
is a little bit more targeted to the
female audience I know there isn't too
many of you on this channel but it is
something that is very important to take
note of so for example my wife really
doesn't like the headrests in the Tesla
Model y for very simple reason they're
not adjustable and they Lean Forward
just that little bit too much so
whenever she has her hair in a ponytail
or a bun she can't really lean back her
head properly on that headrest so if
there was some sort of adjustable
headrest that would have been amazing
even if it was slightly tilted back just
that tiny bit now the white seats aren't
all glorious there is one con and it
basically came default out of the
factory the seat belts do cause a little
bit of damage to the white seats and
it'd be nice if you could fold them away
hide them tuck them somewhere where they
aren't actually touching those seats at
all the front two drivers and passenger
side are perfect they don't touch
anything they actually sit to the side
of the seats but the rear seats are a
little bit of a problem now if you're
going to work every single day and
leaving a car parked somewhere in a
public car park it's probably really
nice to keep Sentry mode on because you
get all the information if somebody ever
scratches it dents it or God forbid
something worse but unfortunately Sentry
mode does actually use quite a little
bit of electricity so for example I only
live about five minutes away from the
office for me to drive to and from work
uses less than one percent of the
battery however for the car to be
stationary all day and to have Sentry
mode on users anywhere from three to
five percent of the battery every single
day depending on how many people
activate and Trigger that Sentry mode so
this is just something to keep in mind
if you are planning on using Sentry mode
don't have too much battery left or you
simply just need a lot more battery to
finish your destination at the end of
the day one of my last cons is something
that you don't actually notice and don't
pay attention to unless somebody's
standing outside of your car and is
going to tell you when you're doing this
so one of the best things about a Tesla
Model Y is that you can play all sorts
of games when you're sitting inside the
vehicle and waiting for somebody to rock
up now the game that's very similar to
Mario Kart is by far one of the most fun
and by far one of the best games on the
system however if you turn that steering
wheel and you're playing the Mario Kart
game what you will never notice is that
the wheels of the vehicle actually turn
yes Tesla disables most of the functions
so that steering wheel is very light and
fluid however your wheels are still
going to be turning ever so slightly and
damaging your tires so this is something
to keep in mind if you ever plan on
playing that game now like I mentioned
at the start of this video Tesla is
considered a luxury car it is in that 60
70 80 000 plus price range depending on
which vehicle and model you get now
before the Tesla Model y we had a
Mercedes and the Mercedes was brilliant
it was very luxurious and it is
typically did a luxury car as well there
is a vast difference in quality and
construction still the Teslas are built
incredibly well and honestly there is no
flaws in our model wire and is near
perfect however you can just tell the
quality of the materials the quality of
the Plastics the leather just isn't up
to the speed and up to scratch of what
Mercedes BMW and other luxury car brands
are however Tesla is also a technology
company they are so focused on the tech
and the updates that roll out every
month approximately are incredible and
your car is constantly evolving and
updating something that the Mercedes
never did in fact if you wanted to even
update your Maps you get charged five
six hundred dollars just to upgrade the
maps on the system so it's in its own
class of electric vehicle luxury cars
simply for the fact that it isn't
boosted by the technology behind it
anyway that's all for me so guys thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed the video if you did make sure
you leave a comment down below and let
me know if you want to see more of these
videos if you really loved the video
make sure you check out the playlist
side of me and there's also the
Subscribe button just down below like I
said that is all for me so I'll see you
next Monday